Human Society is constantly solving
problems like how to most efficiently
move people resources energy and
information
problems that scientists are realizing a
single-celled brainless slime mold might
be able to solve better than us
if you've taken a walk through the
forest you may have noticed webs of a
yellow substance growing across dead
trees and on piles of fallen leaves
moving at a glacial Pace this slime
slowly consumes the microorganisms
living on these decaying materials and
while this brainless blob may seem
incredibly primitive in its structure
Its Behavior is another thing entirely
this unique organism is called a slime
mold and as it traverses the forest
floor in search of food it makes
decisions based on a complicated
trade-off between the risks its hunger
level and the quality of food patches
it's been shown to demonstrate both
learning and memory and acts in such a
clever way that scientists consider it
to have a unique form of primitive
intelligence
in fact its abilities are so great that
researchers are using its foraging
methods to solve real-world optimization
problems such as the shortest path
between cities and the most efficient
Transportation Network challenges that
typically require a sophisticated
computer algorithm
but the applications for slime molds
don't stop there scientists are even
using them as one of the most essential
components in a computer and are
actually building computer chips
containing this slimy substance in a
world that's rushing to implement
Advanced artificial intelligence as the
answer to our problems slime molds show
us that some of the best Solutions might
be hiding in the most primitive places
what even is a slime mold and how can
the simple brainless blob solve so many
problems
slime molds are mysterious organisms
that scientists struggle to classify in
the tree of life because they
surprisingly share some of the
characteristics present in animals
plants and fungi
like social animals slime molds exhibit
swarm intelligence communication memory
and learning however there is one
important difference slime molds don't
have a brain like plants slime molds
have the same structural material in the
cell walls of their spores and organic
compound called cellulose but unlike
plants which famously make their own
food through photosynthesis slime molds
get their nutrition from outside sources
making them heterotrophs most often they
mistakenly get categorized as fungi
which is the kingdom that includes
traditional molds like fungi slime molds
are heterotrophs and reproduce by
dispersing spores
but unlike fungi they don't have chitin
in their cell walls they engulf their
food instead of digesting it externally
and the primary cell type during their
life cycle is diploid which contains two
sets of chromosomes instead of just one
as in a haploid cell the primary cell
type found in fungi
since they don't quite fit in any of
these kingdoms slime molds are
classified as protists a catch-all
kingdom that only requires its members
to be eukaryotes a cellular organism
with an enclosed nucleus it's basically
a category for everything we don't
really understand
there are over 800 species of slime
molds that can be further classified
into a few main types based on their
life cycle one type is cellular slime
molds when food is abundant these slime
molds go it alone and exist as
single-celled organisms but when food is
in short supply they will aggregate into
a mass and start moving as a single unit
this is sort of like swarm intelligence
we see in other animals like ants
however these individuals aren't just
working together they literally become
one entity
aggregation begins when a single cell
becomes stressed and secretes a hormone
called cyclic amp nearby cells respond
by moving towards the hormone many small
individuals come together to create one
giant accumulation one that acts like a
single unit like its own brand new
organism this aggregation is called a
slug which can be between two to four
millimeters long and composed of up to a
hundred thousand cells it moves as one
unit towards attractants such as light
heat and humidity looking for a suitable
place to settle and once it does the
reproduction process begins the slug
flattens onto a surface and some cells
develop into two to three millimeter
stalks while cells at the top of the
stocks develop into fruiting bodies that
contain spores what's weird here is that
these are still technically individual
cells some of which have the genetic
fate to turn into a stalk some with the
genetic fate of turning into spores and
only the ones that become spores get the
opportunity to reproduce the ones faded
to become stock simply die
spores presented in this way are then
dispersed by soil invertebrates and in
the right conditions spores germinate
produce amoeba and thus complete the
life cycle
slime molds like this are true
evolutionary head scratchers almost
always in an organism the multicellular
stage arises from a single cell a
fertilized egg this ensures that the
cells of the organism are derived from a
single genotype all of these cells are
on the same team so to speak they all
agree on the goal of passing down their
shared genotype to the Next Generation
in slime molds the multicellular stage
is a combination of many unrelated
genotypes viewing these slugs with the
same lens of natural selection that we
view everything else in the natural
world these different cells with
different genotypes that make up the
slug are not on the same team
in any given slug selection favors the
cells that take unfair advantage of the
altruistic cells so much so that the
selfish types of cells should threaten
the existence of any altruists and yet
both types of cell continue to exist how
this self-sacrificial Behavior continues
in the face of conditions that should
select for its elimination has baffled
scientists for years
the other major type of slime mold
belongs to the class mixogastria these
slime molds are often referred to as
acellular plasmodial or true slime molds
while cellular slime molds are difficult
to see with the naked eye a plasmodial
slime mold can stretch pretty far with
some species reaching 30 square meters
and despite its sometimes massive size
it in fact is one single cell containing
millions of nuclei and this one gigantic
cell is a master shapeshifter
plasmodiums travel over damp decaying
material like wood and leaves in the
search for food they primarily eat the
bacteria that feeds on the decaying
plant matter making them an important
player in the decomposition process
while searching for food they send out
tendrils in all directions to sense the
environment around them
these tendrils are tube-like structures
with a gel like outer membrane
when this vascular Network encounters a
stimulus the molecule cyclic amp is
released this initiates cytoplasmic
streaming this is the flow of cytoplasm
inside the cell driven by the movement
of the cytoskeleton the rate and
frequency of the contractions changes
when the tendrils encounter an
attractant or a repellent when an
attractant is located which is typically
a food source the rate increases sending
more cytoplasm into the tendril to
capitalize on the nutrients and send it
back throughout the body of the slime
mold this causes the tendril to grow
the opposite happens when a repellent
like sunlight is located or nutrients
dry up resulting in the tendrils
retracting until they Disappear
Completely in this way the slime mold
moves towards or away from the source of
the stimulus eventually configuring
itself into the most optimized pathway
watching this optimization process occur
scientists realized these slime molds
are capable of solving some complex
problems displaying a remarkable form of
intelligence and intelligence that
operates without a brain
when scientists first brought visarum
polycephalum to the lab it was simply to
study the way it moves no one thought
that it was capable of making choices
never mind choices that seemed well
thought out
that is until the year 2000 when
researchers in Japan put visarum
polycephalum to the test in the form of
a maze they chopped up a single specimen
and Scattered its pieces throughout a
plastic maze they then put two food
sources at either end of the maze there
were four possible routes the plasmodium
could take to get from the start and end
points
first the plasmodial pieces spread and
reconnected to form a single organism
that filled the entire maze after four
hours the parts of the plasmodium that
occupied dead ends shrank
the remaining part of the plasmodium was
then weighing its options comparing all
the possible connections after another
four hours it selected the shortest path
between the food sources and recently
scientists realized that the way slime
mold achieves this is even more complex
than they thought
as it crawls through the maze it leaves
behind a trail of slime researchers
realized that the slime mold will avoid
this slime Trail meaning it avoids
places it's already traveled giving it a
kind of externalized spatial memory
since then scientists have been
discovering new applications for ficerum
polycephalum one of the most common is
determining the optimized route between
multiple locations
this is known as a combinatorial
optimization problem where there are
many solutions but finding the best in
this case the shortest path gets more
and more difficult as more locations are
added this type of problem often comes
up in the fields of AI software
engineering and Applied Mathematics and
using a living organism to solve such a
problem could offer some interesting
insight
a popular example of this is a study
published in 2010 where researchers
tested the efficiency of phy serum to
recreate a real-world infrastructure
Network the Tokyo rail system they
hypothesized that the sly mold would
have been fine-tuned through
evolutionary selection and therefore
would be capable of making the same
complex trade-offs between cost
transport efficiency and robustness as a
man-made transport Network and that's
exactly what they found
on a flat template of the Tokyo region
they placed food on the 36 surrounding
cities connected by the rail system and
let visarum grow freely from the
centralized Tokyo location at first the
slime mold spread out evenly over the
food sources but soon it began to
optimize its pattern leaving only the
most efficient network of interconnected
nutrient transport tubes they discovered
that visarum created a map nearly
identical to the real rail system with
about the same cost efficiency and
robustness in other words the
single-celled brainless slime mold
didn't reach for its food sources
randomly becoming satisfied as soon as
it had any food it instead behaved like
a team of human Engineers editing
altering and optimizing the network
creating the most efficient Network
possible and this is far from the only
optimization problem slime molds have
been able to solve the traveling
salesman problem is a classic problem in
mathematics where a hypothetical
salesman needs to visit all the cities
on a map just once before returning to
his origin City the question is which
order should he visit the cities to make
the shortest trip possible
this seemingly simple problem has a lot
of real world implications a package
delivery company might want to plan the
shortest route between stops to save
time and fuel a school district might
want to plan the most efficient bus
route to take children to and from
school this is a problem that's
surprisingly difficult to solve and for
every city or every node that gets added
it gets exponentially more complicated
when there are just four cities there
are three possible solutions when there
are eight cities there are 2
520 possible solutions thus it takes
traditional computers exponentially more
time to solve as they go through each
solution one by one but researchers
discovered that slime mold can solve the
problem in linear time no matter how
many cities get added because it can
process information concurrently
while the activity of slime molds can
help us find new solutions to common
problems the experimental process using
actual slime molds is time consuming so
scientists are instead developing
algorithms that model their behavior in
order to test a number of different
scenarios more quickly
the researchers of the traveling
salesman experiment created amoeba tsp
an algorithm inspired by the plasmodium
by incorporating the real-life
constraints and behavior of ficerum
polycephalum amoeba TSB found high
quality solutions that also increased
linearly with the number of nodes and
now scientists are exploring the
possibility of using slime molds as a
physical Computing medium in a 2018
study researchers created a slime mold
computer chip which is made of a network
of slime mold tubes coated with a
conductive substance it reacts to
real-world optimization problems just
like a slime mold does and the conductor
transmit the information quickly the
physerum chip solves a wide range of
computation tasks including optimization
on graphs computational geometry and
even robot control the dawn of these
biological computers shows us that while
artificial intelligence may be prom
missing primitive intelligence crafted
by millions of years of evolution may
also become a powerful tool in our
toolbox
for slime molds complex decision making
doesn't require a brain but for us it
unfortunately does having a big brain
means that we're pretty good at solving
problems but we're also pretty good at
getting frustrated getting anxious and
giving up it's all too easy to deem
something too difficult even though we
know we're fully capable and that's why
we humans are lucky we have brilliant
brilliant.org is the best way to learn
math and computer science interactively
it's helped me learn how to solve
problems that I would have thought were
way too difficult for me because
brilliant takes you through lessons step
by step and doesn't impede your progress
if you get stuck instead they give you
in-depth explanations to help guide you
to the right answer it's easy to learn
in this low pressure environment and
most importantly it's easy to learn by
doing the interactivity of these courses
makes learning feel more like a game
than like a class the computer science
course has been particularly valuable to
me this is a topic that I've always felt
out of my depth in but Brilliance
courses take you step by step through
things like algorithms data structures
and programming there's even a section
on parallelism which is the very way
slime molds are able to be so quick with
some of their decision making it's the
strategy of solving problems Faster by
doing multiple things at the same time
and it's a concept that's hugely
important in computer science
so to learn how to think more like a
slime mold and to try everything
brilliant has to offer free for a full
30 days visit brilliant.org real science
or click on the link in the description
the first 200 people will get 20 off
brilliant's annual premium subscription
and every sign up helps this channel